i took a walk around a northwest
neighborhood
yesterday not the pearl district
adjacent to the pearl district
um although a neighborhood in which
there has been a lot of damage as well
um you know to the point that you know
some people are still saying as i
understand it there's you know the
damage has been limited to one square
block
like you know well for for a while in
this last summer
um they were certainly focusing on the
federal building
but it was never restricted to that and
it certainly expanded its scope
quite a lot to a few regular regular
places in our regular neighborhoods
but my sense yesterday walking around is
that the facade
on the street is now um is now cracking
as well that there were far fewer don't
hurt me walls
in in on businesses um there you know
there's a little bit of signage still up
the occasional
the occasional black lives matter um
sign and such but um
none of these arrays of don't hurt me
walls which have become
the norm which quickly became the norm
as of early last summer
and what i do see is more indications of
fatigue
and questioning and then these outposts
and individual um homes really of
of signage and so i just i took some
photos and we're gonna walk through them
and
talk about them um so zach don't put my
screen up just yet until i find
these um and okay so you can put my
screen up now zach
um and for those of you who are on
twitter i am
i felt obligated to let paul krugman
have it on twitter yesterday because
he claimed that it was basically a gop
fever dream that anything
was happening in cities that was
untoward
over the last 10 months and so as part
of the thread that i wrote in response
to him
yesterday i put a couple of these images
up so some of you will be familiar with
these already so this is just a sticker
on i don't even remember what some
something um
in a neighborhood near downtown portland
says new portland sucks
now this could be i i could imagine the
person who put this up
meant one of two really different things
right they they could be part of the
sort of anarchist or woke or you know
any number of groups over in that space
who want you know more chaos and less
law and order
and more fear among ordinary citizens
and such
um or it could mean um it could
be the same sense that i have you know
we're newcomers to portland we've only
been here for two and a half years
um but uh actually as i said in that
tweet thread yeah
this this new portland does suck and the
new democratic party sucks and this new
national conversation and the new
national culture that are becoming
reified suck and we can all do better
and we all deserve better
um anything you want to add to that um
yeah i mean i
i do think it's these structures
and they urge us on to behavior
that uh is itself appalling
um but i agree it's not us who sucks
it's these structures you know a corrupt
democratic party that wants to cynically
ride a woke wave for example leaves
those of us uh who
you know would ordinarily uh find a home
in the democratic party absolutely
homeless so
um you know that that is just a simple
fact and i think
increasingly the failure of these
institutions for
several different reasons some of them
economic some of them uh
you know the political corruption and
other such phenomena that that um
leaves us to erect alternatives right
there really is only one
or maybe two choices you could recapture
these things which turns out to be very
very difficult
for obvious reasons or you could build
around them
and i agree i've also noticed i i hadn't
um i think said anything about it but
there is
a an almost searching
for new ways of um
shaping the conversations there's been a
mind-numbing chorus of
you know black lives matter for example
um and then there has been this sort of
people trying to figure out
how to signal yes i'm in principle
on board with the idea of black lives
matter but i'm not on board with the
idea
of you know violent riots or
all white people are racist or uh any of
those things
um so i don't know maybe you maybe want
to show your your next image
yeah so i mean this this is this speaks
to exactly the searching that you are
talking about then increasingly um you
know
the graffiti the tags that we're seeing
um
as of last summer through the winter
through you know the first part of the
spring
really were entirely singled out it was
just this
monotone uh in support
of what turns out to be a divisive
hateful um
series of actions and now we are seeing
things like who are we
right and then however same neighborhood
i
happened to walk by a first floor um or
ground floor
apartment with a whole lot of stuff in
the window so
here's here's one of the windows at some
distance
with for those who are just listening
rather than watching i'll show close-ups
of three of these but
several several of the signs that we
have
become accustomed to plus a whole lot of
hello kitty figurines which
struck me as something i hadn't seen
before super ominous
uh oh i mean you joke ish but um
i have been talking with some people
elsewhere
um behind the scenes about the
the connections between some of what
we're seeing and some of these
subcultures
um including anime and the rise of some
of this very
very physically disconnected social
constructionist thinking
so i'm not sure there isn't an important
connection here no i
i was only partially being ironic hello
kitty
in some sense i think because it is like
um you know designed to be the opposite
of threatening is actually a very good
cloak
for some other stuff and i i've also
seen it uh
used as sheep's clothing more or less
yeah
so here we have a close-up of what are
the one of the things in the window
white apathy fragility ignorance and
silence
feeds into violent systems of oppression
so i'm just showing these i mean this
was interesting because there's
literally a crack in the window in front
of this and it feels like
this kind of you must ex this kind of
message which for months and months and
months in portland and to some degree
nationwide to some degree
internationally
was the only note that we were allowed
to publicly agree to
if we uh if we wanted to be accepted in
polite company or something and having
literally the crack in the window in
front of this
um seems
like a hopeful metaphor maybe
here we have this hand-drawn picture of
hello kitty
literally saying black lives matter and
then i don't know what the
thing in the puddle next to hello kitty
is but it's stream thinking
abolish the police so
i i really don't know what's going on
here
another crack in front of it um and then
then this defund the police with a
cartoon image of a of a pig in military
and police garb
saying i'm just following orders and you
know there's
you know he's crushing blm protesters
underneath his
giant piggy police feet um and it says
a-cap at the bottom all
all cops are bastards so you know this
the same
the same rhetoric right um but again
this is one
apartment that i'm seeing this in so
let's just run through these before we
before you want to riff on these
um next window over same apartment i
think uh
we have defund the police share the
bacon
um queer power black power women power
all power to the people
and then protect black trans lives
here's a close-up of
that one um just notable here you know
black trans lives matter we spent some
time
talking about what what the heck is
trans doing and black lives matter all
of a sudden
uh last summer but um i believe
and i didn't actually spend as much time
with this as i was hoping to that
there's
literally one trans man on here and the
rest are trans women and that's of
course consistent with the idea that
this
um that a lot of the um
politicking behind raising the um
raising the the rights and visibility of
trans people is actually specifically
about men
um who are declaring themselves women
and very little in the opposite
direction and there's
something very important and deep there
and we're not going to go there right
now
um defund and demilitarize and
dismantle police um in case anyone was
still confused about whether or not
defund
actually means these other things at
least in some people's heads yes it
actually
100 does um again with some weird little
like hello kitty-ish characters around
the outside as if to
make this seem like it's all sunshine
and flowers messaging
and finally sort of shades of audrey
lord here
dismantle our house build the new
um they do they want to dismantle what
they're viewing as our house
um and they say they want to build the
new but i've literally never heard a
policy proposal to that end i've never
heard even a sentence to that end what
will the new look like
there's the it's you know they're busy
declaring themselves ungovernable
and um and they'll be satisfied with
nothing
there were there were violent protests
the night that biden was elected the
night of the chauvin verdict you know
no outcome will suffice yeah i mean
it's almost as bad as it is that there
is not a single idea on the table
um that is credible it's even worse than
that because what is said
clearly tells us that the people who are
so
confidently telling us what we have to
do to fix civilization
uh either can't or won't think right
so for example um the idea that we
shouldn't call the police
when one teenager is about to stab
another um because teenagers have been
fighting with knives for
you know forever and i'm not even sure
what the conclusion of that idea is
supposed to be
is it okay that they've been fighting
with knives is you know
how true is that doesn't any reasonable
situation
prevent teenagers from fighting with i
mean it just
it's nonsense yeah it's nonsense um
but you know let us just say again i'm
worried about
the um the death of the
counter-intuitive
right so we've talked a lot across
heterodox circles about the importance
of nuance
and this is really another facet of that
same
gem which is the things that make the
west
great right to the extent that they're
intuitive they don't require comment and
everybody else has them as well
to the extent that they are
counter-intuitive then
we have to hold not only the thing
itself but the explanation for why
that thing works right and so here you
have a bunch of people
engaging in another
uh counter-intuitive right the right to
say anything
right and i would protect their right to
say anything up to the point where
they are calling for you know
the death of andy no or the murder of
police and frankly that reference to
bacon is
right on the border right um
but other than that should they be able
to say defund the police
yeah should they be able to say abolish
dismantle should they be able to say
all white people are racist hell yeah
they should be able to say all that
garbage
doesn't make it true but the point is
their right to say that
is the you know it comes along with our
right to say here's why
that's garbage right here's why that is
insane here's why
if you believe those things you don't
belong anywhere near the levers of power
because you're going to
you're going to wreck the ship that all
of us are depending on um
so in any case you know the irony is
that that
uh the uh abolish the police
movement is also very interested in
dictating what can and cannot be said
and um to bring this around to where we
started
the really interesting thing they have
been
very effective at policing speech right
not by punishing those who speak right
they're only a certain amount
successful at that but it's the thought
for every person who speaks up and is
punished
there are a thousand who self-censor
right
and so this exploration of you know well
okay i
am for that but i'm not for this other
stuff you're saying
right this attempt to parse the
distinction between
the um the fraction of the message that
does the heavy lifting and then the
payload
right um that exploration is about
people waking up to the need to figure
out how to say these things and i wish
frankly they were being a hell of a lot
more courageous about it but the fact
that they're doing the exploration at
all is hopeful and the fact
that uh um mayor wheeler
is recognizing that in fact you know
what
they're gonna say shitty things about
him right but they're going to say
shitty things about him
anyway oh yeah right no matter what he
does he cannot appease
the mob who literally declares
themselves and i i didn't find it but
there are a number of places
in the social media feeds of the of the
self-proclaimed anarchists
saying we are ungovernable and i believe
they were they were marching with those
signs
literally the night of of the night that
biden was elected we are ungut we are
the ungovernable we are ungovernable
um you know burn it all down why would
you try to appease people
who say that right especially after they
spent the entire summer pretending that
the violence was about trump
right and then the point is some of us
have been saying nobody's pretending it
was about you know
and and about police violence and all it
wasn't just trump of course
well i agree but i mean in portland a
lot of it was you know trump sent in the
feds trump's
right right and so the point is cause
and effect were inverted
and you know they're gonna say terrible
things
about mayor wheeler no matter what right
we're going to say
terrible things about mayor wheeler to
the extent that mayor wheeler is a
terrible mayor to the extent that he
comes around and starts
uh acting in portland's interest we'll
say you know what we're pissed off about
what went before but thank goodness
we're headed in the right direction
like we always say to our children it's
about the future man it's about that
it's about the future can we get it
right from now on it's about the future
and
so what did you learn
[Music]